but first the colonial pipeline is back
online
but america has been exposed in a
massive way
this pipeline system was hijacked by
russian criminals
shutting off fuel to the entire east
coast of the united states
gas prices which were already on the
rise spiked even further
thousands of stations still out of gas
as we speak
and things likely we are told won't be
back to normal until sometime around
memorial day
that's a couple of weeks from now and
tonight we're learning the colonial
get this they paid a 5 million
dollar ransom in their desperate attempt
to get their systems back
online um joe where was the federal
government on this
uh why was colonial left to fend for
itself against international russian
criminals
or did your administration actually
approve
the ransom payment to russian criminals
because you know
ransom payments in case you didn't know
that incentivizes future attacks
uh why not do it again clearly worked
the first time
and by the way what are you gonna do
about russia joe
what are you gonna do about your friend
vladimir putin
have you called vladimir have you maybe
even asked zero experience hunter to
call his russian oligarch
friends that paid his company millions
of dollars for no experience or maybe
just too tired joe
but here's your nightly reminder joe
you're the president of the united
states
we're gonna have to respond here joe
what are you going to do
now true to form today the cognitive
mess that is joe biden
he didn't seem to know anything about
pretty much anything take a look
as for the people who carried out this
attack the fbi has released details on
the attack
so others can take steps to prevent from
being victimized like
colonial has been we do not believe i
emphasize we do not believe the russian
government was involved in this attack
but we do have strong reason to believe
that the criminals
who did the attack are living
in russia that's where it came from
we're from russia
we have been in direct communications
with moscow about the imperative
for responsible countries to take
decisive action against these ransomware
networks
can we get the 5 million back in ransom
no clarity
no strength no leadership whatsoever
that means america's enemies they see
all of this happening and unfolding
and they also see how weak joe biden
is and now we are living out the jimmy
carter
nightmare all over again frankly on
steroids
inflation look at this up a whopping 4.2
in april that is the highest number in
12 years
that means every single consumer good
you buy
at the grocery store at your drug store
lowe's
home depot it's going to cost you more
every single day
massive gas shortages up and down the
east coast look at your screen
half of all gas stations virginia
georgia south carolina
are out 70 percent of stations ran out
of fuel in north carolina
even more 73 percent in washington d.c
good things winter over winter's over
because joe would be telling you to turn
down the thermostat
and put on your sweater to conserve fuel
just like jimmy carter did now when
america's enemies
are walking all over us and when they
can see a weak frail
cognitively struggling president and
when they know his fledgling
administration is ready willing
to appease wherever whenever possible
they will and they are already all
taking full advantage
joe foolishly already reinstated what
hundreds of millions of dollars in aid
to the palestinians
40 days ago likely being funneled to
hamas
in these attacks against our ally israel
they are attempting to ease sanctions
against the world's biggest state
sponsor of terror
iran they're the ones supplying the
rockets now being used to strike israel
and commit acts of terror nationwide
worldwide rather
and thanks to joe's war on american oil
and gas well we're now buying more fuel
from of all places russia
you can't make it up which along with
iran and china we now know is supplying
weapons to yemen for the proxy war that
they're fighting in the middle east
there
joe's weak his feckless policies are so
terrible
that now 44 senators have written a
letter to joe
hey joey they're begging him not to lift
sanctions on iran
as the muellers are funding and
supplying the ongoing
hamas terror attack to our friends in
israel
why on earth would you give a dime a
penny to a country that is actively
trying to destroy
your greatest ally in the middle east
the number one state sponsor of
terrorism worldwide
you know death to israel death to
america burning
israeli flags american flags it's
not just a meaningless chant it is
backed up by
constant terrorist actions weapons
training could you imagine what would
happen if iran ever develops nuclear
capability
that cannot happen that could end in a
modern day holocaust when you marry
radical fanaticism of the muellers in
iran
with weapons of mass destruction that is
a danger
too eerie to think about too chilling to
think about
but according to the radical socialist
base of the democratic party
oh they're standing firm on their belief
that israel
the victim is evil here led by the squad
leader congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
she wants you to believe that israel
isn't even a country
just an occupier of stolen land
apparently she wants the millions of
jews in
israel to just get lost and hand over
the keys
of their thriving democracy to the
terrorists in hamas
aoc's fellow squad members the case in
this case congresswoman omar
well she just accused israel of ethnic
cleansing
congresswoman talib said that benjamin
netanyahu should be tried for
war crimes he can't make any of it up so
from the squad we see it before we see
it now
and that is yeah virulent anti-semitism
remember what i've been telling you the
squad runs the democratic party the new
green deal socialism
that is the squad's plan nancy pelosi
chunky schumer joe biden fear of the
squad
and when they say jump well they're just
asking how high
given this kind of logic rhetoric is
anyone really surprised that an
anti-israeli
protest in new york well that erupted in
violence
as the crowd attacked a passerby leaving
this man bloodied and bruised keep in
mind
the left rarely has anything negative to
say about hamas
they are a terrorist organization that
oppresses the palestinian people
uses them as human shields they often
fire their rockets from schools and
and hospitals they vow in their own
charter to wipe israel off the face of
the planet
as part of their quote struggle against
the jews
unquote thank god for the iron dome
which you can see here in action we
showed you last night
this technology was developed in
partnership between
our allies israel and the united states
in a better time in a better place
it shoots rockets right out of the sky
and so far hamas has launched a whopping
1 200 plus projectiles into israel many
of them
aimed at high population areas why for
maximum
impact and maximum damage and death and
injury against innocent civilians
without the iron dome
dome the human cost would be
unimaginable and breaking tonight as we
speak there are now israeli troops
amassing at the border with gaza hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else